on peut se faire un petit plaisir et si
on aligne un jeu tous les deux eh ben
c'est parti on le rejoint dix mois rouge
jaune et noir pourraient faire le juste
euros
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça va être très simple on va essayer de
trouver les prix des objets j'ai mis des
lunettes parce que j'ai vu que l on va
se trouver le prix des objets dans les
années 90 et donc le j'ai besoin de vous
philippe je vous donne le micro
oui je suis un spécialiste des années 90
- non pas du tout géré des villes je
sais peut tourner donc moi je donne un
objet vous devez me donner le henry en
euros dont vous faites la conversion
vivre à la maison
olala et vous vous débrouillez très bien
et après je vous donnerai le vrai prix
en mer on s'adresse à tout le monde ou
un parent non non pas déconner si c'est
un parent c'est exactement
allez on commence très simple il est
pour un euro et audio compris à la jeu
le jeu payant qui part en sucette en
face à tout à l'heure
on commence par le prix d'une place de
cinéma dans les années 90 adhérents
vous savez vous grâce à cinq francs non
mais on parle pas des années 30 de 0,10
à ses plus bas au plus froid de ces mois
à 4 ans et plus
valérie diallo
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour ça que je voulais fuir parce
que même avec le prix c'était pas la
bonne réponse jusqu'à 65 correspondent à
30 francs à l'époque mais aujourd'hui si
le rose or on and on peut lui tonne me
12,3 euros
aujourd'hui avec 80 bas d'une place 80
ha bah ouais mais bon c'était 30 francs
et ça c'est intéressant de voir aller
une autre alors là on part d'une on
parle d'une célèbre paire de baskets on
va pas donner la marque et vous allez la
reconnaître alors c'est parti à layher
20 euros c'est plus 30 euros fait plus
c'est beau euros
je
90 on va tout à fait me ferai deux fois
et demi n'ont pas pas tous pas tout non
mais méduses et bien comprendre le jeu
là vous avez le muppet show qu'il ya un
minibar et qui change
[Applaudissements]
vous me faites vous fait enlever votre
doudoune chercher si la djezzy de meudon
allez un sujet d'actualité le prix du
litre d'essence dans les années 90 au
moins 80 centimes sentir mais maintenant
ça va aller à l'époque c'était un euro
c'est ordinaire c'est ça il avait super
ordinaire il est demeuré l'ordinaire et
gasoil adorent ils me regardent c'est
comme si j'étais à la pompe moisi
j'étais super ordinaire
vous plains film les niveaux des gentils
allez on part sur un os et qui enfin un
vêtement qui ressenti a pas longtemps
une doudoune très connu on dort à la
marque
ah oui alors c'est bon c'est pas son
bien soit 180 euros
c'est plus c'est plus en plus c'est moi
c'est plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
137 euros mais à l'époque à à 930
aujourd'hui y avait un canard dans le
dos et le foot est maintenant oui mais
non ça vaut 400 euros elle est dernière
on va faire le prix d'un téléviseur
écran plat s'est fait plus précis enfin
c'est le début à salé le premier
vidéoprojecteur
on va prendre l'équivalent on a pris
pour que ce soit comparable une marque
est le plus grand des croquis de six
téléphones rétros contient pas assez
calmes alors 5000 de plus ces mois dits
bidon c'est plus vivant plus c'est plus
6 milles 9,6
non c'est plus c'est de suivre depuis
1800 non c'est plus de 18000 290 on sait
moins c'est plus faudrait pour continuer
[Applaudissements]
c'était un vidéoprojecteur à cristaux
liquides et voilà les avaler vingt mille
francs 18 295 euros
on sait aujourd'hui un grand écran de
cette taille à la marque ça vaut 200
euros ouais bien la maison
ah oui on est content mais vous avez
revendu à l'époque pour le payer merci
beaucoup philippe
[Applaudissements]